this is a production of cornell
university
this part is
some conclusions to the research it's
mostly
my experiment going out when i think
about not trying to put some way to
communicate with the
brother
by a biology community and find some
help
or some collaborative
future interaction for the for research
i do
and
this particular presentation
i have to start from the end
don't get excited i recently for another
this is not my airport really this is an
effort of many people
that are spread all over six continents
and speaking 20 or more languages and
they are really the ones that
made this impossible
by
putting up my questions and my annoying
being pretty much annoying and trying to
force them to help me
and also this is the network of
everybody in the room in form of it
just tax payer as long as you pay taxes
if not then you're not contributing to
this paper you
his research
and i have to also pay
my respect to the 19th century
capitalism
and the smell of foundation that started
my research in this area
so
since i started from the end i'm going
to give you a title
and
when we look at the background like this
when we go to the
field everybody sees something different
some people see volcanoes some people
see snow thinking about skiing and when
i go there i see plants mostly big trees
and
even more i see
the specific
part of the plant
the conducting tissue
and when i look at it i always ask the
question what makes plants a plant what
makes the plant to be a single organism
that has its
hundreds or sometimes thousands of
distal organs placed on the branches and
millions of rootlets in the soil and how
they function all together as a huge how
do they imagine without having a neural
network without having a brain so from
our animal perspective we think
everybody should have some translated
signals of environment to make it
respond to the environment
in a coordinated manner and here we have
the plant that doesn't
have that
kind of
ability to anticipate or
perceive the environmental cues
ship them to one place
digest them make this information
decision
and then spread them back to say okay we
need to do this or that in this
particular region of the plant
and
when i think about it what makes khan
depart the most
amazing part of this is that
whatever we go to field right now
especially around the
corner you go to the forest and you see
not plaques you just see
the
tubes that conduct water
covered by bark and tubes that look like
sugar under the bark
during the summer right now they're not
doing much but they're just standing
there you see basically big conductive
tissue you see the huge microfluidic
device
and to give you the
kind of a
feeling
what is this scale of this micro fluidic
device
you can look at these numbers four
million kilometers
of tubes are in the single
eucalyptus tree which is ten times
distance
and thirty trees put all the tubes from
the tree we reach the sun is eight
minutes of life travel it is a huge
amount of microfluidic system way more
than humans have in form of their
vessels
or even nervous system and this
xylem tissue is also
matched by the little bit shorter but by
flying transported transport shooters
from the
think it is it means that those
transport tissue they have to somehow
in my opinion at least interact and
pre-create this system
response this is this is this part what
we call right now this is new word
emergent properties this system of the
tree has these emerging properties those
transporters that has emergent
properties of coordination
among those distilled parts of that
so
the observations i have
kind of over the last 10 years of
working with drugs
that all
almost all biological responses that
i've studied have always byproduct in
forms of the hydraulic
properties adjustment or changes in
hydraulic properties whether it's needs
roots
xylem tissue or fluid there's always
no matter what kind of
element we study whether it's nitrate
sugar transport whatever category is
always a component of hydraulics
and i try to convey the message that
this hydraulic component may be the past
dynamic
part of the
microphone risk of this macro leading
system
that
can allow for well increasing increased
well-being
basically can make the pump
function in more
efficient way
so the puzzle that we have
is we have those whole levels the
difficulty of studying this kind of
question of this kind of a
paradigm
is that we have to study
some kind of a stick to shower but
anyway we have this
part of
a different scale from molecular scale
subcellular same
scale to true to medium space of several
centimeters when we have tissues
interact to hold let's say in my case i
like to sew the whole tree and how we
can combine all those elements together
is a big question
challenge technical challenge
so first i will try to explain or not
say just
put you in a through the
way how i thought about it why can't
they come up with this idea that they
have to this microbiology system has to
be a part of the
informational system in trip by the by
looking at three different unique
parts of
through three different unique
responses of plot to particular
environmental triggers and how they
translate to water
adjustment hydraulics of fats and how
they can eventually meet
the
this premise of emerging properties that
they call plants
so i will go through three examples root
nitrate update sugar transport and
concentration of co2
and this is the first it's about root
update and nitrate update virus one of
the observations that i made recently
was that
when we apply nitrate to previously a
little bit starved nitric starch plants
of course nitrate presence will trigger
dietary transporters nitrogen be taken
out by root but at the same time we
noticed that plant increased extremely i
mean extremely but within very few
seconds within 30 seconds changes its
hydraulic properties of roots by
allowing more water to go through the
membranes of parenchyma cells and
and this
this two slides show
tomato and cucumber
and the
a and b chose tomato become the response
to nitrate addition to the solid
solution and then the blue line
shall increase versus control green line
show the increase of flux through the
root
completely
unrelated
to any changes of
driving force this was not caused by
changes driving force highly pressured
braking or small degrading across the
road it will just change by the cellular
adjustment of cell
cell properties which is the lower graph
shows the
test of the
half-time water flow through cell
membrane in the parenthema cells
and
bars show that
application of nitrates to roots
will require required costly drop in the
resistance of membrane watercolor
so here we have this nitrate application
resulting in the
chant in the
properties of hydraulic properties of
fire
and so
what causes at the molecular level this
change we are getting was of course
aquaphoring but
we were trying to find out what how this
signal of nitric translate is what
what creates the change
in micro
between membrane components what part of
this nitrate transfer cut creates a
change and this is
we use the tongue state time state
applications to decide whether we're
trying to block the
nitrate assimilation but with time state
hoping that maybe some by-product of
nitrate from hydrogen as the innovation
but will
let us
decide which part of the pathway is
responsible for adjusting water
component of the
quadratic cloud
and we successfully stopped the response
of nitrate
on cucumber but not on tomato
with time state when we checked in both
cases the
nitrate until nitrate
the
nitrogen simulation part was blocked in
both cases but in case of the
cucumber we also noticed that we blocked
the
uptake nitrate transporters into the
application of time state so they gave
us a very nice simple experiment to see
which part of the pathway is responsible
for the
for changes in aquaporin activity
because tungsten
in tomato the other one
shows the
nitrate in tomato
taxi tomato blocked the nitrous
dissemination part but did not do
anything to
to
blocking the reporting activities when
we change when it when in cucumber
and cucumber
we chime we block nitrate transporters
at the same time we
block the active activity of aquaponics
at the same time so they they did not
not block that they did not respond to
the presence of lightning so it was
obvious that nitrate inside this cell is
responsible for increasing the
conductance of the
membrane so we injected nitrate glue
back all of the cells and we
get back
we activate the cochlear implant and
increase the water flow
to the cell so in this case i did kind
of a short inside of the cell but
at that point i
as i am a whole plant biologist i
kind of let this go to the
people in my lab to try to study what
molecular level responses are involved
in this type of
response when i went to
bigger picture try to understand why
factory father changed nitrate activity
with
by adjusting the watercolor
and this is an overview of the
concept that we had is that
in when there is no nitrate present
basically takes up water and nitrate as
they are available in the soil however
when
when suddenly one place
nitrate which is a mobile nutrient if
the soil shows up due to the rain event
or some activity of microbes around one
part of the root system
each plant would like to take it out but
as it triggers out the nitric
transporters up regulates nitrogen
transporters might be clean the nitrate
presence in the surface of the root so
it would be beneficial for grams to
bring more nitrate lower the root by
increasing the flux rate of water
so if it can change the flux rate over
the root
then it would be
automatically increasing availability of
nitrous it's a feed forward effort and
when over time
plant nitrate is
it is mobile nutrient we shift from one
spot to another
plant can turn off water resistance i
mean turn out the
uptake of water in one part of the root
system move it to another part when the
nitrate is present and again
benefit from having the
flow range toward the root
and this was the concept so
we then tested it
on hydroponics and we built a new system
with two roofs
split root system two balances and then
we provide one
part of the
root with the
with the
nitrate
and
you can see on those crops that there
was immediately met by increased water
dropping from this part of the roof and
the other part dropped down the optical
because they need the plant is
collecting water from where the hydrate
is and when we rotated the roots they
immediately switched back and nitrate
became the
plant with nitrate the roots with
nitrate presence was able to take up
more water with migraine when the other
one was shut down which gives us the
feeling that this is an interesting
example of
seemingly unrelated processes nitrate
updating and water up when one is really
increasing the potential
of the other turning on the water from
nitrate gave us and gave the pump a
chance to take up
to benefit from taking up more nitrates
when the nitrogen is available but also
it gives us
this static
distribution of roots in the soil
with mobile nutrients that can shift
from time to time from place to place or
can be triggered by microbial activity
in different places you can temperature
degrees of water available
this can
allow plants
despite being immobile to chase
nutrients
by adaptation of physiological activity
turn on here rules and the calculations
in the other one so this is one of the
examples of how plant can adjust
hydraulics
to
seemingly non-related
physiological activity
so we can put together two pieces of
puzzle two different levels from
molecular several levels to hollywood or
part of the root system level
the other example
that comes from my study is the
interaction between sugar
transport and
anxiety transport
this is a very simplified view what
happens but
when sugar is transported
there is expectation that there are some
ions being recycled over time to
maintain the sugar flow from the shoot
to the root
and
interestingly when this happens those
ions goes from
fluorine
it goes from chlorine to xylem tubes
and flow up back to the
cells at the top of the plant and this
is interesting because destroying
this flower
the presence of ions in this island can
change
the resistance of the xylem itself so
those the tubes that are in the flow in
the xylem they
conduct water
and for a long time they were assumed
that they are
permanent pictures that they like act
like pipes but they like 10 years ago
you find out that they're not acting
like
mere pipes they they are
also dynamic you can adapt their
resistance to waterflow
they can adapt resistance to presence of
ions in this item that can come from the
zeitgeist interaction and these are the
graphs that shows increasing flow rate
of
in the xylem different concentration of
potassium in the in the sub
and
percent of related flow fluorine
due to the individually desired tubes
and this was later on we showed that
this is really
related to
border pit membrane properties
these are border physically with our
links between two adjacent
vessels in the plant
one of them here
one of those
one of the border pits here is open and
you can see through so this water goes
to one side
to the other side of the vessel to
another
vessel element
to those border pits that are composed
of
the hybrid materials composed of many
fibers gels and
potentially some parts
and when we look closer closer at the
scores
they are
this is a recent afm analysis of the
border path itself
when
just two fasting images shows two
different moments two different
uh
properties of borderline memories the
one on the left
shows the membrane is produced
this is the space
i think this is
this is the this is the
elevation image of the
afm atomic force microscope when we
probe the surface of it and you can see
that this is
this is kind of a flat surface very
difficult to
to distinguish anything underneath this
fiber structure of the order fit
membrane is hidden under the general
kind of material and when we expose it
to 50 micro molar concentration of
basically this gel in those border fits
it collapses making it much more
strict and much harder surface and much
more features on it we have potential to
see the
the
fibers these are black
lines here they
and
also you can see you can see kind of
long quick clarification you said 50
micro mole over this means i mean
sorry in this case it's 50 millimolar
yeah
because we wanted to get it very strong
usually in plants it goes from
a few from from 2 millimolar to 7
millimolar here is we wanted to see the
big change and we did see it and if this
change collapse the gel
to make the surface much stiffer but at
the same time much more permeable to
water
and again this is the microscope
those images were showing this
is this interaction of ions being
recycled from flow and
at the might end and then microscale
level
change at the
structure of border with membranes and
when we look at the whole plant level
we can try to understand why can't
bother to change this micro
micro
through the properties of this micro
fluidic systems
for is there is there any physiological
meaning for it or biologically for a
well-being of the whole map to do it we
did a long time ago with peter meltzer
here we did this study of
when we took the plant
this was a tobacco and we took parts of
this island attached them to
tubes and then we flow in one case the
eye water in our way the i was randomly
substituted the eye water with
artificial stuff composed of true
whatever we can read in the book how
with artificial stuff and then the
moment we substituted with the
artificial stuff the part with the
substitution
was
increased dramatically the flux rate of
water from the particular part of the
pump allowing to say that
composition of salt
can really change the rate of
utilization of water through this
particular heart anxiety when we go back
to the
water
the resistance increased and the water
update decreased from this particular
zone
so this is a really complicated system i
this was everything so far was done
and
outside the plant or in case of
with artificial sub here i wanted to
decide is it true that by dealing with
or
changing the property of transport
employment i can induce changes in xylem
rate of water delivery to come
so this is a
setup where plant
was tortured in extreme ways
by the fact that it was pressurized in
the roots it was on the balance then we
changed the light condition humidity the
top
to
and to affect the flux
and then it was also
the flight was gurgled to change the
way that time
uh
to to induce the flop to to force plants
to stop transporting the time and
eventually we are able to measure
between two transducers t1 and 2 we are
able to measure resistance of this
island and
also
determine from
the rate of water flow in the plant
which allow us to find out that indeed
with moment when flying was disturbed
the resistance of xylem increased
dramatically so it is
completely related one to the other that
as long as plant can recycle ions can
maintain
it can maintain
preferable xylem flux conditions if it
cannot transport ions
i mean the recycled ions through the
decline
from glyphosate
the resistance of plants
to water flow dramatically increases
and how does this
play the role in the whole plant
environment interaction that's that's an
example that i can think about but i
would like to
later on
to study in details but in shape
conditions with all those
aspects of low photosynthetic activity
low export rate low ion circulation
this results in high resistance to water
flow so those parts and plants that are
in shape they may not get water
in opposite situations when one of the
parts
one part of the body is exposed to sound
just entire activity of transport and
recycling alliance increases the
capability or
capacity of xylem for water transport
and
can enhance water delivery to most
productive plant parts
so this is again a system where those
minuscule changes or unrelated seemingly
unrelated
part of plant biology like blind
transport and recycling of ions can
force or can make
induce
the
increased productivity
plants in
areas when plants really needs this
particular
situation and you can envision that over
time when sun is going in the forest
different parts of the
tree crown will be exposed to sun at a
different time and only those that are
getting most light will be most
supplied with water and ions from the
from the side
third so this is another part is you can
put together again a cellular level or
sub-cellular leather information
with
tissue level adjustments and improved
performance
next example is coming from leaps
this is something that i am studying
currently so i don't have a nice
description of it however when leaves
are
i mean they compose you know they
compose
a lot of cells but mesopostals and
conducting tissue cells and when we look
at them
the interesting aspect that we're
finding out right now is that presence
of co2 inside cells changes the
aquaporin activity
in the cells too this is again a
by-product of our foreign activities
that allow or stop
water being delivered to and injure
ourselves or changes resistance of water
being delivered from zion to epidermal
cells or plants
and interest
the interesting part is that the more
co2 there is in the leaf
the more resistant is the pathway
between xylem and
stomata and the more resistance is this
pathway it means that stomata has harder
time to get water so if there is any
loss of water they will shut past them
and how this will play in the whole
well-being of belief it might be that
when
it might be the leaves that are in the
shade i.e they are not productive they
have increased level of co2 because
there is no much photosynthesis in the
juice so if those leaves can reduce
the loss of water
then they will automatically
preserve this water for most productive
beams that need water and they can cause
a lot of water so if they reduce
the water loss
due to the department they have higher
concentration around them then they will
be able to
utilize this water in other parts of the
plant similar to adjustment of
resistance to design
so this is the third puzzle i mean not
two puzzles together again we have
cellular component
co2 uptake but at the same time it
translates insult to aquaporin
and affects the ability
and lost water
so in this case we have the
little elements
smaller research components
getting us to
another
steps emerging properties of the entire
system how those little parts can create
a plan
that is responsive to
environmental cues
and trigger some
higher level and organismal level
adjustments
so
this is the question i have how to
understand the vascular network if it's
composed of
millions of kilometers of
vessels and
millions of cells
that compose that provides
capacitors for water and there are those
resistances between cells and this is
just i should just
make it a
bigger picture but this is just a small
part of
the equation
and
to start it we we have this problem that
all those
this research has to be done on the
vessel the conduct water under tension
so any disturbance to it makes it
possible to just stop the transport or
they done in deployment which
is under positive pressure but then the
disturbance to it also stops the flow
this time proudly
and
interestingly
anything that i try to do is met by
this this fact that this is from
methodological challenges is
very well confirmed by all the reviewers
that i have to meet on my way
since and this is no additional chart
just send you letters that are longer
than your papers and why
something is wrong with the methods
but unfortunately they never say what i
should improve they haven't been
criticized but that's okay
so fighting with it i i have to
why this is difficult because scales of
a preservation we have to observe
something you get microscale
and
and somehow translated to tens of liters
of the tree
there's as i mentioned before
everything is in the plant every
transport is intra cellular there is
really no extra cellular
xylem vessels are cells
and flaxseed machines are not outside
black sevens inside the plant views
everything is small
and they under tension and
they under high pressure so what we can
do
i tried so this is a long term project
so it started many years ago
and i think that age stroke will
recognize this little device on the left
with probably that his first attempt to
measure or just
create the tension in the microbiome in
my biomedical device when we're trying
to measure load of
generate transpiration in
microfluidic device and measure tension
for the first time
this was
not silicon what was this pdms
and of course the moment we did this the
first thing we always get was embodies
at the time when we connected to the
tube there was an embrace and no more
just spitting function
but
so the next step i did with
was to develop an artificial leaf
where we were trying to
generate fluxes not through it really
but through the bubbler
and all those examples of what i tried
to do they end up in some kind of a more
or less
published material except that they did
not yet contribute to answering the
major questions
but i hope
but like this one this this paper
this this evaporative device allowed us
to create a better understanding of vein
vein spacing in the path
what drives the white hole in fact eight
millimeters of lane this
weight many millimeters of vents per
square millimeters of
beam tissue versus let's say
uh
that had one millimeter of anchor
millimeter of surface of it
this device allowed us to
design or better understand the scaling
of the nation if we use
the other part so this is this is kind
of an overview of method that i try to
develop to understand the
well-being of fun so this is by a
beginning of the device that we
bio that we try to understand the flying
cloud
in using the first micro
microfluidic device when we are able to
separate two
two micro channels with the
semi-permeable membrane and analyze the
rate of flow
versus the concentration of sugars and
size of the plant tubes
which gave us the ability to predict
why certain plants have the tubes that
are like try to cover this a 50 micron
diameter clam tube when the uk industry
has
constructed about 15 micrometer diameter
tube
or why
tomato has 25 megapixel 100
despite the different sizes different
distances that this artist transported
and this is a scanning law that we
developed when we can
predict the leap size
might be the loading
sample for
for for photosynthetics to employ
is related
to
i mean times one third of the
power of stem length gives us the
predicted rate radius of the of the
planet which is kind of an interesting
finding
that
can
be expanded across a lot of different
sizes of plants from arabic galaxies to
become industry
also so this
these are the viability part now i try
to develop methods that will allow me to
look inside the plant and this is one of
the methods that i call the remote
access methods this is remote access
deployment mode where i loaded the dye
into the leaves and
then
i'm able to follow up due to the
bleaching of diet the rate of movement
of dying time
allowing me to
determine the
rate of flow and hopefully also to
decide
later on right now but later on to
create
to expose those plants to environmental
triggers to see how loyal flow rate
directly affects other particular
hydraulic properties of the plant
this
is
this is another part
i try to loop into the leaps
when i
try to
measure the rate of flow of water into
the knee
to have
to to determine
if i trigger a particular part like if i
change the
availability of co2 in it how is water
flowing in particular parts of the new
change so this is a movie that shows
that i came right now entering the
distribution of water across the river
again i am missing this little part yet
how to
get to
exchange
this is another card so this is bleeps
this is stem this is a
work that we did on trying to look
inside the stem of the ground using mri
and this movie shows it's kind of
very short you can see this black
little
kind of
sorry
this little black
speck going
through the um right now
this is an anabolic formation in the
plant so this plant was under stress
this plant
was in mri and
at one point we got disturbance from my
from us to the plant
there was a
particular event that showed that there
was employees later on this up here
this so mri proved to be very
hard to look into the
well-being and water distribution in the
stand which gave us an immediate look at
what happens to water in this case the
blue is not water but blue is air what
happens to air inside the plant during
the embolus events how is it distributed
in three-dimensional scale all the time
and how it disappears which proves first
of all that embodies can be revealed but
also shows us that we can look
at macroscale and microscale events that
happens in vietnam
so this is another now we're going below
ground this is another part of this
system this is
root access
where
when
we make the on-time observation of water
uptake by europe you can see that water
disappears from
root and shows
we can calculate how much water at what
time is being taken out by one
particular pump
and this is the two pictures here it's
after two hours the color brighter color
they were covered in red
more water was being taken up at that
particular time from particular zombies
and you can see that two are in the park
in this particular system we have to
shift the water update from the top to
the bottom and again i this technique is
developed
to hope to make it possible to put
together
some
additional
like other nitrates to this system and
see how this nitrate will influence what
they're having on the soil
the problem
okay so there is another car so there's
more more of those there's insider
inside i call it because then we try to
do
looking inside the planet very
microscopic very small levels to see
droplets in vessels or
how the heat look like inside during the
active transportation these are the scm
pictures
so they not really show the active or
real-life elements but at least they
gave us the feeling
how the environment looks like so when
we try to model it later on we can get
the true dimensions from the system and
learn how they interact with the
environment
and direct access
to plants this is a micro probe that we
poke into design
and the pressure graph here shows that
i was poking going in the xylem probe
pressure to the town and eventually i
force it to
to generate some tension
and
most likely
embolize it a little bit because
and then over time
the pressure probe reached the higher
and higher pressure of almost two bars
and at the end
i i was not in the room in that farm no
one was in the room it suddenly hit
what i call the repeating moment go down
to negative pressures and embolize the
game
so this was this is an example of direct
practice to silent and observation of
embodies revealing
and last the moment
is the last kind of slide here this is
i try to overlay all those physical
measurements of system on
whole transcriptome analysis
check what genes are being triggered at
particular physical events
during the
during the
time
i mean
if we
force particular spots like force and
this is cycle about anybody's repair if
we force plants to embody and then wait
for repeating we can check what pathways
and what
particular processes are being
upregulated due to this response
so each of those
techniques that i use
require some kind of a miracle to happen
each one is extremely complicated
and i call every researcher miracle
and when we have 10
different aspects to measure
simultaneously it's a huge miracle here
we have to measure
50 or 60 different elements
simultaneously at a big macro scale and
it's extremely
interesting from the perspective of how
to do it and i don't know how to do it
yet this way going around us people
and put together the picture how this
plant is capable of responding to a lot
of stimuli
and how this local stimuli spread across
the hydraulic system
and how they interact with other kinds
of stimulus and how they create this
hybrid i call it the high drug
informatics how they do this
hydroinformatics will allow plants to
interact with environment and create a
created
shape the tree
that
that is well adjusted
to the environment and how those
changes influence the fluxes inside the
pump
and
make the blood work all together
and
so now sorry
now i can go to the beginning which is
from micromasters of microbics and say
how this hydraulic integrated blockable
autonomous responses
are being
are made plant vascular system to be the
dynamic coordinator of everything that
happens in the country very narrow very
short areas
and i i know i'm not too long hopefully
45 minutes
any questions
um
but it takes few years probably so i'm
just looking rather for people
or for themselves but
just using some information that you can
provide but i mean this is
as i said this is a very difficult
problem from the perspective of
combining all those
measurements into one big system
and every time we try to measure
something it's one miracle we have
so modelling is going to be a big part
of it
and we use models to even model the
biome by
mimicking devices
where we know everything about the
system and we still
have to model parts of it
to understand what's happening here so
indeed it's been more difficult but for
the for example structure of the
internal structure of leaves makes the
boundary conditions
i mean it is not easier it just makes it
more difficult
do you have a hypothesis about how co2
effects at the
uh foreign is as i said it is kind of we
started to do it recently so we don't
have the hypothesis however
we i don't have
a clear view
how does
events
of
the nitric oxide
we would require probably
one hospital for two graduate students
to direct
you know analysis of
expression of some genes or activity of
proteins and
i don't i don't even imagine how to
start thinking about these signaling
molecules which ones are being
responsible for it
we can probably predict
whether concentration of sugars are
important or
what what whether ph
in the cell was due to co2 concentration
might be important which is a
possibility because ph was shown to
affect
so you increase co2 level chinese ph of
water in the hypoplastic might include
which part of it is
responsible for the second lifetime
so here you're going to also have
there is a lot of things that co2 can
just affect very general question the
experiments that you do are almost seem
to be
directed toward trees
yeah because
but in any case
do you
do similar experiments on herbaceous
times really small plants in these
qualitative differences
they i can i show trick because i like
them but unfortunately most of my work
was done on unfortunately
on the herbaceousness i mean i do for
semi-finals but we work with cucumber
tomato
tobacco
soybean
and popular
and many other trees
i
have kind of a question rhythm
not
specific plant
so if i have a question and i go
downstairs to the greenhouse of the room
and i find it on
it's good for me i learned the name
later
so i really don't mind what i'm starting
to put on again the confidence there
and often we have i just don't i just
gotta just take the first time and i can
you know this was nice this one
and then i asked the people what
but i like since i work with arnold
arborito
i like free so i always show the tricks
so it seems to me one of the problems
with modeling is you latch on to some
idea
and then you model everything around
that
and you
as a result you may have looked
something else that might be more
important
but
the instance is that struck me
is when you have shade versus sea
sun leaves leaves in the shade versus in
the sun
most of the water was going through the
leaf in the sun
you suggested that this was because the
leaf was
photosynthesizing altered the level of
co2 the co2 all the water flow
but
the most important thing with regard to
transpiration is going to be temperature
and your shade leaf is not going to be
at such a high temperature as the
sunlight could you not explain this
entire movement
on the basis
of temperature influence on
transpiration rather than going and
worrying about the small changes you're
liking against co2
i i'm not trying to explain the level of
transpiration and trying to explain
the resistance
yes
of course the sun temperature there will
be more transpiration in this summary
and if you have a constant resistance
let's say one
the drop of pressure
with particular level of flow
you'd have i don't know
another one let's see one megapascal
drop across the factory
however if you can drop this resistance
half then you for the same transpiration
rate you're dropping pressure would be
on the half
so your you will be able for fun to be
able to keep stomata open to sustain
this transpiration without
dropping the pressure
so what i'm trying to say is not how
does this influence the transpiration
rate but how fun can we distribute
limited resources between parts of
plants to most productive ones so yes i
wanted to be transparent as much but i
wanted to do the
low pressure drop so they don't need to
jump shut stomata
if you increase resistance the load is
suddenly
suddenly there will be not enough water
capacity transport capacity president
and stomata will shock transpiration
will be the same
but there will be no
production because there is no co2 out
there
okay so it's not about how much water
goes to particular parts but how one can
manipulate and redistribute water
between the parts
right at the beginning you're talking
we're talking about sort of thousands of
buds and repeated parts of plants i was
immediately highs
and that you know sort of to some degree
in sort of a hive organism
all these different uh
you know individually capable parts but
somehow achieving coordination
to what extent do you think that you
know if you're modeling the resistances
of your
your examples tended to focus on sort of
the
proximal
uh functional aspects of what was
happening locally in the changes of
existence but
what extent do you see that as sort of a
long-distance communication pattern sort
of like the bee
dance where the patterns of resistance
and the resulting hydraulic properties
patterns of water potential are actually
sort of a
communications network that allows the
different parts of the plant to
coordinate yes so as i said this is a
dynamic project yes i do
you know that there are a lot of
capacitors on this
schematic
and of course
if you if you have this
system with some capacitor which sells
certain capacitors the spread of
hydraulic signal or changes in the
in the distribution of the retention
industry or changes in distribution of
pressure in deployment
will
not be instantaneous across the plants
they will happen in time and then
depending on the disturbance level they
can disappear at certain distance so yes
the the degree of the
response or the
the way that thumb is constructed or the
capacitors of the of the system they
will influence the spread of
hydraulic adjustment of the plant
and
in any way this is
i think that this hydraulic can serve as
a kind of a fast dynamic first level
response it will be later matched by
all kind of chemical responses
that are required by
physical delivery of something from one
part of the plant to another and it is
probably
another level of
response that i am not studying but it
would be very interesting to see how it
changes in distribution
the fast response
much later is much later on by
phytohormone distribution and other
signaling molecular distributions
but i do think that it's not
it's not on the short distance local
chain but it's spreading if one part of
the route changes the water potential
inside the root this signal or
i would call the signal but this
the change in one part because it's
interconnected will influence
distribution of potentials or tension in
the entire system to certainly
other questions here
are there questions in geneva
um
first of all i want to thank you for a
really
thought-provoking type of a seminar
and really a seller all the way to the
try to explain things for four player
bases
on the very first section that you had
with the root uptake and the nitrite
and maybe i just missed in the detail
but what was the concentration where
you're seeing these
influx or the changes in the flux rate
of the water
so depending on the plant we we were
trying to to use plants that are having
less nitrate than in the cropland so
basically between one and below one
millimolar
of nitrate in the field conditions
and when we change it to about one
millimolar they were already responding
to it later on we used basically 0.5
millimolar and 5 millimolar is kind of a
fast
frustrated change
but
we try to use the more
natural environment concentration for
nitrate than properly
how rapid on the
response to the internal
economic resistance and the
relief with the sun versus shade
how quickly would that respond
because if we have
for example clouds go over
or
sun moves and these go in and out of
shade
uh how quickly
did that response occur and was it
equally reversible
at the same rate
you mean
this
i don't have right now the dynamics of
it and how fast it happens right now we
are at the level of
enthusiastic
wow that we can
see of good affects and so basically we
collect
we do mostly
the physical
we can measure the response
within
several minutes right now
maybe you can think faster but i cannot
get higher time resolution
so we see that there's evidence of
between several minutes
you can
in aquaponics
so how do you depart the effect of the
nitrate
on the root water uptake and then the
effect of the nitrate on the hydrogels
shrinking
very easily uh what i did i cut the
roots
applied the nitrate at the same
concentration and i found
the effect of
like 10 percent or less
versus the flaxes that were manipulated
by by nitrate undamaged roots that are
40 or 60 percent which suggest that it
was mostly
resulted
from the root and also the resistance of
the radial resistance of the root in
this particular case is about 50x higher
than the resistance of internal diagrams
so 10
change in diameter
translate to less than one tenth of a
percent to 100
of the total resistance
of blood so it was meaningful comparing
to what was doing in response to
medication
now i have a second question to that so
what about the root cap or the
rhizosphere zone where there's a gel
there is that responding to ions and
affecting
water absorption at all or if you had a
chance to
throw like different salts on to the
system
everything was just behind me but not
behind very close to super ice dawn
like 80 to 90 percent of water was
flowing close to the sugar ison when the
tip of the growing part of the roof was
responsible for less than five percent
of water out there so even big changes
in the
properties
it might change in the dry soils when
the root growth
well
magic will be here through tomorrow if
you uh would like to uh get a meeting
with him that's probably possible to
come up after uh right now um
let's thanks watch again for us
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu